on this week's show should you invest a
property close to home in the news
renters are still confused by a tenant
feet ban and we're gonna be answering
all your property related questions
welcome to the property investors
podcast thanks so much for tuning in
make sure you subscribe so you never
miss an upload you can catch us on Apple
podcasts Spotify and YouTube enjoy this
week's show and don't forget to share it
with all your friends
I also lades I'm Alistair cutting out
how and welcome to this week's property
investors podcast got an interesting
show coming up cause I know we're gonna
disagree and argue yeah well I think so
but I'm not for a bit of an argument I
saw for debate yeah the gloves on it's
always good if you have difference in
opinions and anything I don't agree with
the way you dye your hair come on this
is not bad come on it clearly is I've
never dyed my hair I'm alone I was with
you for a week it was going great by the
end of the week and that's gonna say sit
with you and then sir the late looks
blond again I have never dyed my hair
and the reason when agrees because I was
with you for a week and I had two days
off and it said it sort of relaxed I
mean I can go lace gray now come on that
is the worst excuse I've ever heard in
my life
trust me spend some time of this big
recovery but anyway what have you been
up to this is my friends are going gray
mmm maybe it's you a dry wit and you're
like completely awkward sense of humor I
don't think I'll ever go gray I don't
think you will but well I think I'll be
bald before I go correct and that's the
next thing for me I was looking at here
transplant solid day I thought you were
look at hair transplants in order that
when you had one
he wasn't like cuz you don't wanna be
that guy do you that's like balding to
hear and then suddenly comes with a full
head of hair
oh right but the fact that you've now
told it will mean looking at hair
transplants yeah you know okay you
should be that guy there I don't want to
be that guy so get them done so I'll get
it done sort of sooner or later
lean forward no go on
but give us a bow so just think back I'm
just and just you know a little bit of
hair loss at the back maybe maybe it's
the hair dye maybe it's sort of made you
go
there's the peroxide mailbox it does
that do them yeah anyway so what we've
been up to this week
obviously the price of moving house yeah
which you are - yeah
well I'm the senior you don't even show
him pictures of your place no it's in
its next door to kill one tube station
or literally come out the tube station
and you've got like 20 steps and you're
in my apartment
so I've got an apartment there's an
apartment complex
they're called Jubilee Heights Jubilee
and it's yes it's our apartment and
they're really really nice inside and
outside okay it's all right yeah it's
nice it's nice thing it's near made
available and things that are so it's
nice
made a veil and they just offered you a
ruled so it's a nice area quick quick
and city center London the apartments
beautiful inside that it's really like
it's fairly high end so it's not modern
modem but it's very very high-end it's
very like like plush they although do
you know in the communal areas like
they're not like typical what you'd
expect hard floors they're all like
really thick lush carpet all the doors
are like solid wood doors when it's
actually really really nice wood doors
yeah but let's they're not like fire
doors they don't look like conventional
fire doors there are five doors but
they're all done up very like very
antique II like the build a bit like
this but um it's actually very very nice
and said no it's my comedy nice and it's
got a swimming pool and it's got gym
it's got concierge
it's got gym you'll be able to soar what
full workout plan to use it at once do
yeah it ones no no I do plan to use it
also need to continue continue losing
weight I've lost a lot but wait wait to
lose some more nice time
awesome how'd your please yes it's very
nice it's very nice so we'll move yet
but but but we're settled in in terms of
got everything ready yeah yeah so yeah
you've got your movers ready you're
packed and I have now having done that
Ivor
oh yeah no I meant to be moving in like
a few days I haven't even booked a
removal put plan
I'll saw it yeah yeah well I'm gonna
sneeze in a minute so like you know you
might have to cover me okay so well-well
Russell's gonna think about sneezing I
think we should talk about how it's
quite actually quite rude to sneeze
sneeze on the podcast I thought my [ __ ]
the feeling is kind of gone it's still
there a little bit but maybe I won't
it'll probably come out in a few minutes
you are us like a loud sneeze er are you
like our hello you're the car you own
these over-exaggerated like you'll
probably find out and surely hey you
know these people that sneeze
ridiculously loud and it's like come on
dude shut their Jesus how exaggerated
was that I'm not allowed sneeze that
anyway right I will come out shortly
except you know you can just be do you
know we probably just upset the guy with
teeth would you know the guy that got
really upset about how we talked about
teeth and now it's a dressing area he's
gonna be mourning again that we're
talking about it sneezing yeah maybe
maybe I feel it but that's Karen what
was just what we talking about because
so the topic for today's prod podcast is
should you invest near where you live
it's a very good topic I think as it's
come up a lot recently as well I've been
speaking a lot of people been asking
that and things I don't know what's your
take on what before I tell me you'll
tell you my take you show me you show me
yours I'll show you mine okay okay so
alright okay I know I I think as long as
you got good management in place you
don't have to invest we live I guess a
wedge where would you where would you
encourage someone to the best wherever
they can get good return on investments
whatever fits their strategy whatever
fits their cash cash flow whatever
whatever fits whatever they're looking
for so it depends what you're looking
for it's not a straightforward saying
this person should invest they are but
why they need to have a reason for it it
all comes down to that then dividual
internet investor so for you
it doesn't matter where it's purely a
case of wherever there's a good return
just invest there okay so when I look to
invest I look as long as it's a good
return on investment
yeah as long as cash flows good yep
pitch offs his link to our wine as long
as I have a good good people in the air
a good teaming area so for instance is
this part of the country I don't know
anybody so I wouldn't invest there until
I know them people there
because I don't want to be managing my
properties and I don't want to be to go
into them so I the mask that's super
critical to me I must have a power team
in area ie builders good let an agent
and just somebody like a handyman that
can just go ahead and do their job there
they're the most three most critical but
late an agent is the by far the best
because if you find a good Latin agent
you'll find a good contractor because
they will have contractors but I
actually I was expecting you know I
movie but actually I think we're all
gonna argue about this based on what
you've just said hmm so like for
instance and the other criteria is the
property has to be wherever I've got our
decoration team a painting decoration
team and even paint decorate all my
houses and it has to be within the
distance they'll go to because they use
all the same paints the everything's the
same
let me ask you a question yeah alright
you've bought a couple of hates roses
hole haven't you hmm how how have your
property isn't all rented out for you
your rights about okayed not the fastest
but okay how long did take Oh two months
too much to fully let mmm and then
they're been pretty much fully that
sense yeah one of them has one lungs
been a bit what sure I don't know what's
your average occupancy right in home so
one lung has been tented fully the other
one has got in a minute it's got 210 it
it's got three times but one limbs not
pin the rent so they're getting kicked
out and other rooms never been filled
but it's the box-room we talked about
this last week it's the one box room but
that will feel it will feel but that
property's only been available for three
maybe three months okay it's just been a
bit slow to rent so your other one you
filled it because I won't be feeling
quite fast your first yeah the other one
feels literally went to mark on the
Monday by the Wednesday we had four
tenants moving in there were people
there were it was um what cause I had
moved over from Paul and do here for a
year they've taken it on for a year okay
my point and say basically Wow the ones
and some ice actually sounds a bit crap
to be honest but the other ones I was
pretty good but yeah but you've picked
you pick ones in an area of where now I
know other people that I've got paid
most don't live in all that bought them
in Hull where they've been absolute
disaster yeah yeah why is that III don't
know without looking at their specific
properties I don't know but if it's the
if it's the people I think you're
referring to the if it's the perfect
know why just wives one Radian whole
work that looks like it would be good
and what looks like a be good not
working on why it's just a market
demands for that area so would you know
which road at work and which word
wouldn't my president my late an agent
does you do know I I know where the good
ear is doing I and this is my point he's
trying to dodge around the point o
answers no I know where the good areas
aren't hold at what yeah that rent out
but that information just comes that
comes that's not from me that's coming
from my agent but only but because I've
got a good relationship with agent in
the area i beaned a whole lot you know
the I do know there but I've been told
Lots yes I used to got there every
Monday for like I went up the hill every
single moment of resonance right have
you ever bought a property in an area
that you don't really know you have
where Darlington you don't know Don to
know I don't but the people I'm and what
can we do that's the thing okay so the
this is all about Luke would you invest
somewhere we don't live yes you would if
as long as you know something there that
knows what they're doing you don't have
to be the experience thing so I don't
have to be the expert Darlington to know
that property and based on walks in
Darlington I don't have to all I need to
know is I need to know have an agent in
Downton they knows that what about if
you have an angel you don't and you ring
them up in Utah house it and they go
right this air works Terry doesn't you
go brilliant you buy it and that agent
was talking out their ass well then
that's that's down to your due diligence
because why would you take the word of
one one person so okay so here's the
question there because I think we Connor
this is the advanced what the advantages
by way where you know right advanced use
my way knows you know yeah you know
you're not relying on over people yeah
hunt I know Wolverhampton yeah I know
Berman I can get okay that area work
that area won't but I just know you know
I live here right of course player if
I'm buying in dogs and I don't know so
I've got two options right option number
one is I go up I has been spent a lot
which i believe is what you did in the
hole I've done that not which is kind of
my point was gonna be but you've kind of
ruined it but took my Darlington okay
but my point was you've been to Hull you
know the area really well come on Remy
you saying to me - it'll work that
Street won't work they'll work and you
know now if you're buying blind mm-hm
and you're just going up in you go that
house looks nice how she's near the
center well oh great
when you buy it that's where you're
gonna get stung yes because you're not
doing your due diligence on the house
right and if you know the area yourself
it's a lot easier to do that do gooders
because a you live there so you're a lot
closer do you know it anyway yeah so for
me it makes sense to invest in an area
near where you live that you know if and
this is the big if if it's tax yeah
right so for me if it was like right
you've got a house here in Birmingham
that I believe will make twenty percent
or I could buy a house and darlin twenty
percent ROI got house and relatives
gonna make twenty two which one do I
want to buy I'd go the Birmingham one
yeah because makes a little bit less but
it's not much difference I know it I
know it's gonna work that one's out on
my I don't know the area although I have
a support house in Darlington but it was
a barrio for a different thing right but
I'm not gonna be keeping it long-term
I know the air I know the crack but
right so I think that if you know err
it's great however if you don't know the
area then you not what you've done you
define people but do how'd you do that
find people to do you need to get out
there and start looking and meeting
people you're not I don't think it's a
case of you can just open your laptop
and just call like blind in the score
there I'm gonna buy a house they are
you've got to get out there you've got
you've got I think you've got to either
know somebody that knows that area or
you've got to go there right what you
can find over a deal saucer in an area
that you don't know where they've done
as long as that deal sources reputable
then yeah that's not a problem but no
problem with that as long as that deals
was reputable because Jayla like when we
send deals out our deals come with our
power team we have every single deal we
sell out has a parity mean area people
suddenly we've somebody we've known and
trusted so that I said we pass them on
to you but don't just think this is
where a lot of people were wrong when
you buy off dual sources they think
they're just because it's come from a
deal source or that it must be the best
deal in the world it's not the
the the and it my guaranteed everything
that's not the case you buy it from the
deal sources because they're cutting
your leg workout
they're cutting a leg workout for you so
they've made it simple for you where
they've been out they viewed it they've
done all the DD they've done all this to
know that they're then dispersed
facility and giving you a package and
says bang this properties here this is
what we think is gonna stack up to this
is there's all them from information
about it
now it's up to you to make an informed
decision ultimately you're still buying
away from home that is a little bit
safer but I still think you need to know
the area low bit or you still need to
have them contacts obviously band
producers you get in contact which is
fine but so depends on trust it depends
on the trusting and depends on the
ripped the reputation of ideal source of
they're a bit dubious why you buy using
them um secondly if don't trust me don't
buy off me it don't bother me but you
got to know and like the trust you know
like and trust the people you're dealing
with and that's in any business not just
any business any business why would you
the business from but my views on buy
and close to home there are neither here
nor there I will buy clothes oh man oh
by far away it doesn't bother me and I'm
not scared of buying far away like I'm
talking in a minute but buying a house
in Glasgow I have no idea but Glasgow
just cuz I'm score something in New
Glasgow I don't know it I have no idea
about it but they Scottish did you know
no bizarre and but anyway they like up
they are there's there's some really
good Parkins to be add like bargains
absolute bargains and I am fine I know
must live there or something haha no
just because there is there's some
really cheap houses I'm talking houses
are check'em they're not high-end all
people live in London or Scotland I hate
London yeah that's true it's crazy it's
because like okay then asked you ask
this ask the listeners where would you
rather live London or Scotland like
there's a big difference because London
yeah but would you read theirs off see
London hustle-and-bustle
Scotland peace and tranquility what
would you prefer
I was up in Scotland a couple of weeks
ago and I love Scotland that's where I'm
from I know I like the make but I don't
but it's just it's so quiet it's just so
quiet not Anna not other cities but they
can out Scots and that's it and it's
lovely but yeah after three or four days
it's like mmm cabin fever I want to get
I want to get like back to hustle and
bustle and even the cities are not like
the cities down here they're very
they're still very that evening ten
o'clock we were out I want to go out for
dinner at like 10 o'clock at night and
we were in Edinburgh and you know what
it was a nightmare to find somewhere
open a even a restaurant even they
caught a quail that was open at 10
o'clock at night
we barely found that we found a salsa
bar so we went into a source of like I
saw saw like a Latino so a nightclub
type place but even there they'd stopped
serving food so we were just in there
like just drinking yep
drinking and partying another one of my
nights out some of these head on the you
know after that Samsung party yeah
somebody posted on the the YouTube
channel that and the one who em stop
talking a--probably they should talk
about allister's nights out I don't have
actually have that many I don't know
what he always says this but he just
doesn't like that man he probably uses I
knew the go out unless you know you see
me go out yeah with you Artie Yuri and
grabbed by three or four times so yeah a
week let's move to London it's like
every night it's a Friday night every
night every night it's a party night
back on and back on back on area then
yeah so as long as you do your duty I do
think it's important that you have that
you have a patch because you can't no
everywhere can you know and so I think
you need to pick an area right and also
that way it's a bit more a bit more nice
bit more specific so you're not just
like oh yeah wherever ever you start
okay I'm gonna buy that I'm gonna learn
about
investigate that area if it's the way
you already know brilliant yeah and we
were talking about as we went around
move rent to rent I would always go
somewhere close yeah yeah always cuz
you're not buying it doesn't matter
about the value okay this just has to
ask what is the main reason people go
away from home is about cheaper because
they can buy a cheaper because if you
live in the south you can buy two or
three houses for the cost of one house
yeah but that doesn't fit all investors
a lot of investors don't mind buying
more expensive houses because the
benefit always better maybe better from
capital appreciation so it depends where
you want your returns if you want your
returns like in cash flow like monthly
then that's fine maybe they maybe buy up
north but if you want if you're prepared
to wait and gain capital appreciation
but maybe not make as much or a similar
amount among the basis but have to put a
lot more cash in then perhaps so bottom
line is you don't need to buy clothes oh
we agree on this you don't need to buy
it it's it's better it's easier if you
do I think as II it's always you've got
a shout out maybe you better cuz we got
a few means it's closer you know the
area it's easier to however you don't
have to but as long as you pick
somewhere those have got a good return
on investment yeah but you that you can
learn about and treat as if you yeah
then then you good do we agree on the I
are completely ruined brilliant
fantastic hope you guys well it useful
wit now is time for this
[Music]
so in the news this week
Alistair's brought a brilliant news
story to the table no no it's just what
it is is there's a lot of renters are
still super confused regarding the
tenant fee ban they don't actually know
the the law regarding it you know the
law yeah basically from whatever little
area up there basically you see what
brought the start engine was the BBC
released an article basis in let in fee
bans renters are confused as a change in
law and there was a there was a guy who
posted on he went to rent the property
he posted it on Facebook the BBC picked
it up and because he was still getting
charged although he got tires 180-pound
for admin and referencing and it was
after the June the first crime
commencement date for the the fee ban so
he you got a lot of a lot of the
comments and a lot of reviews from it
and you've just been charged something
yeah I've just been charged but that was
really good so I've been charged 350 in
what admin phase and in no not in
service in service fees for the building
so I couldn't be bored with argument so
and so basically what they've just said
is this things so basically you know
they're not allowed to charge you for
referencing checks for any sort of fees
any sort of checks or new paperwork
admin in that what they are allowed to
charge you for is deposits obviously
obviously and let me just there's a list
here so the only payments you can be
asked for in England are the rent
security deposit a holding deposit for
them to secure the popped off and pick
off the market value fare that can only
be a maximum of one week range run one
week rent and early termination payment
so if you decide to break the term the
contract early they can still charge you
a fee for that yeah but it must be
clearly defined in the contract and a
change of the share or fee so if you
replace base if you replace a tenant
they can charge you for that and if you
lose a key or security device such as
the electronic tabs and Forbes you they
can charge you for that and they can
also charge you still interest on late
fees they cannot charge you for any pay
for work they cannot charge you for any
admin but it sounds like you were
charged for admin I was charged for do
you know what it was right
I was charged in total the one week's
rent which my in my new place it's about
behind it's about four hundred and four
hundred and forty quid a week right so
it was four hundred and forty plus 350 I
was charged why was 790 deposit so I was
trust 350 for one week's rent was that
was a holding deposit to take it off the
market
yeah for 40 and then 350 for like
service and building charges I knew it'd
come out eventually
there you go bless you since I
ridiculously over-the-top sneeze well no
that was all right noticed until you
said I dis come out anyway and then I'll
trust 350 for something but you said I
get that back when I move in so I don't
know exactly what it's for and I just
couldn't be bothered with argument I
wanted the property taken off market so
you get it back so it's just one of us
already but I just don't understand
where it's all coming from but I should
have questioned it really because
obviously what we're doing we should
have been handy no but the thing is a
lot of sharers a lot of renter's are
confused by this because you imagine
Durin's you sound very confusing the
main no it's not confused to me but
means basically though if it's a deposit
or if you screw something up we can
charge but we can't just charge you for
the whole process of moving the thing is
that that there is unscrupulous estate
agents out there's and letting agents
and they'll not stage with letting
agents and they may they could label as
something else and I don't know they're
getting away with it are people still
peeing it because they don't know the
law because they're confused about it
and they still happy appear and I mean
if the problem is if if tenants are
still happy appear because they want
that apartment and they need somewhere
to live that's how it's always works the
bus see I think that you should be able
to charge them for reference in face so
do I because why should the Lessing
agent call that fear it's gonna have to
be letting you know it's gonna be the
landlord so why should we pay because
you want to move into our apartment yeah
my and then like I say we've like when
you buy a sofa if you have to pay them
that to reference your yeah
so for a credit check that's interesting
I never thought of it ah that's actually
very interest and when you go to DFAS
and bias
they don't tell ya a 75-pound to do you
don't go in and they go sorry we can't
give you credit a 75-pound was doing the
check please
no that's true actually
but I think we have discussed this
before in a previous episode maybe Nick
can put a link in I don't know but I
think we both agreed at the time that
the why can't they just cap the fees if
there's such confusion why can't they
just say yeah fine but the maximum you
can pay is like a hundred pound just cap
it cuz it's almost like I think it seems
other than sort understand where the
confusion is I mean I don't know what
this story with this guy I mean maybe
that maybe you're right maybe they're
screwing over or whatever but it doesn't
say I think it's very confusing it's
like deposits yeah talk about deposits
though I mean this for renter renters
this is great news yeah there's no
tenant feed ban and stuff like that
because it sets the standard for anyone
ever meant to rent has been a lot of
talk and I know you've actually used it
the zero deposit scheme yeah so I've got
the opportunity to use this at my my new
apartment as you a deposit scheme yep
and so you don't pee really it's not
don't think for one minute is zero money
in because it's a zero deposit you have
to pee at court you have to be a fee for
using the sewer deposit yeah it's a lot
less than the deposit it's a lot less so
like like for instance I was gonna have
to pay let me just calculate it quickly
I was gonna have to pay for forty times
five twenty two hundred pound so I could
that was just be my deposit plus then
four four eight times four point three
three plus twenty two hundred so for me
to move into this new apartments gonna
cost me like four and a half thousand
pound pretty much yeah so I can reduce
that down to just one month's rent
advance and in one week's deposit a
hundred and forty pounds and but where
the zero to put scheme the way I've been
told by my current air letting agent is
you can do zero deposit you pay one
week's rent as a fee for setting up that
and that's like an insurance policy and
that covers your deposits but you never
get that four hundred and forty plan
back but you don't have to pay the
month's rent the month's rent deposit so
it's good if you're looking to move but
the truth is you very rarely get all it
was it back anyway to you I don't know
do you
I've never rented me a lot they always
fought trying for we the one landlord
Ida right running with it was like
literally he right he's such a dick
lesson for you though right he was such
a dick so he he was very hands-on and he
verbally told me I could do things like
we would you call it menu by rolls of
turf Rita the muffler guarding yeah
turf the garden because the grass was
crap poor patio is like he came he's
like yeah yeah we're at chat it was
really sad I thought right then when I
moved out he was like I'm gonna have to
dig up the patio I mean all these nice
changes I had done he was all my
paintings buzzing back because you've
put a patio down about permission and I
was like you gave me permission I spoke
to you yeah he'll like show it prove it
yeah yeah dick even though you've added
value to his property and about made his
garden nice he told me he paid to get it
torn up so I'll I went and looked over
the fence and status there it still was
yeah he's just been an obsolete and I
ended up settling with him out of court
because I hats taken to call to get my
money back you know it's small claims
right pain in the ass I just could not
be what would with it yeah I ended up
settling because I didn't want to go to
court I had no evidence or any proof but
well at least with this I've never got
my full deposit back
there's always something it's worth
doing zero deposit then four hundred
like one week's rent upfront yeah they
always knocked something off oh you
didn't you know he left one other slider
my guard and there to pay for it see it
removes my 100 pound not something but
yeah yeah no I think the zero deposit
sounds sounds really good yes that's
good way but look just get clear on it
when you're moving get clear and ask
they're letting agent what you've what
you're paying for is at an admin because
of Asda shouldn't be charging you but
let's say BBC picked up on this guy he
was a bit annoyed that you got charged
but he felt he was in a catch-22 because
he wanted the apartment he had nowhere
else to go so he felt he had to pay for
it he's moaning about his one Jannetty
quid now he put it all over Facebook to
get a bit of sympathy you know that's
what people do right it's now time for
your questions and our answers
[Music]
and now it's time for you guys questions
and me and Russell we'll try our best to
answer them so we have a question here
on Facebook from Joey Peters hey guys
hey Jonah
is one deal package per week heavy going
or can it be sustained
I am fully determined but don't have
much time can this be done part-time I
will start how about a Freddie Freddie
Mercury mustache no nobody would all be
gray cuz he won't want dyes mustache
now everyone right okay so hey Johnny um
look why don't you have much time ask
yourself is that a job stopping you from
have a much time because if you do want
one dealer we can make three grand does
your job P 3 grand
I don't know I don't need your situation
if it is your job I would start looking
at minding your own business as opposed
to mind in somebody else's one deal a
week is very sustainable say I just
don't agree with you
I'm not saying about baingan I miss a
lot minor bit right did you know that
80% of millionaires yeah are employed
yep okay but let me just see what Johnny
Peterson does so I'm not gonna give too
much information about Bo I'm on on here
but let me just check out is because
this is very very private place called
Facebook which if you research them okay
so I highly suspect he's not a
millionaire so um so and I highly
suspect I suspect most dill sources
aren't yet millionaires I have a
complete review and I highly suspect
just because only one in 500 people are
millionaires yeah so it all depends dude
what I don't know man why are you busy
is it is it family commitments or is it
work if it's work then you got to wake
up where you'll earn more money what
would you want out of life what do you
want out your work I don't know maybe
doing a couple of deals a week or even
one deal one is the real a sport nice
foot
so you do one day away as for do Sam
unthe some 2 grand is 8 grand a month is
your job paying you 8 grand a month I
don't know I don't I don't know your
situation duty but what you can't tell
him is how long will it
him to sauce one Dale awake you could do
one day a week in a day quite easily
that way their weekly Jesus iodized for
a John you could do it you could do a
day a day road viewings and are they
doing all the the back end stuff so -
that's not that way they are in the
viewings and then are they doing
back-end stuff so two days a week and
then a day doing admin no - three days
away stop listen how many days a week we
tell you to sauce one deal away copies a
week you should be reviewing surely you
could get like more than one day alone
day air so could you don't do it in what
day awake is difficult to see enter I
could do a lot quicker he could do I
don't know a skill level well how'd you
know you could do it you're judging his
skill level or not okay right maybe I
did a little bit Johnny I don't know
your skill level dude right I hope if
you're better than me then happy days
then then you shouldn't be questioned if
one deal Susilo okay so listen get out
there start looking find some deals when
it starts paying more in your job quit
your job and focus on at full time and
they should love your job if you love
your job happy days I hated my job if
you love your job happy days I've always
loved my jobs always right on that no my
opinion is one deal a week is very
sustainable but you could very quickly
rank one up to two days a week tear two
deals a week and that's what I see but
it's up to you dude nezam hold on we
just have to cut this incredibly
important podcast so Russell can answer
his phone
okay so next question from a guy called
Jimmy here would I live abroad and we'd
like to invest in rent to rent si as a
hands-off investor what return would I
expect with say five thousand pound
investment
keep up the good work lads you're a top
crack cheers Jimmy so if you've got five
K to invest and you want to do it hands
off how are you going to acquire the
deal are you going to do yourself which
I assume not because you've said hands
off so it's looking like you want to buy
one from a source or so if that's the
case and should be enough to get a rent
around for a sorcerer and pay for it
shouldn't it I would see me you may need
a little bit more because you're gonna
add Eason Trent Trent you're gonna be
sort of four thousand pound
a thousand for the sauce anthe and then
you will need money to set up and paid
the power i don't do we don't do rent to
rent not very rare do we do rent rent
deals very rare
I find them very very difficult to pass
on as our as our investment as I'm not
an investment but as our I find them a
very difficult deal to sell on or to
pass on because I just yeah we just
don't do that many we do one probably
one every couple of months and if the
director vendor three leads that we know
they're not generally through agent so
and it's not something we would ever
probably look to so if you found himself
are gonna be enough for SHINee and that
five grand would be enough to set any
property art really but if you buy it
from a sauce you'd have to add the sauce
and beat to that so and you depend them
but you very varies on rent to rent do
it with five grand you could be made
equal making like 100 percent Arawak
Larry yeah a hundred all right but and
another thing you got look at is how
much cash flow per month now I'm pastor
I'm not interested in rent to rent less
it makes a thousand pound a month
I'm just not English guys it'll be like
over two hundred percent ROI so I think
usually get a thousand pound you if you
got in the right here you can me if I
was in the month if you handed it over
to someone like like a management
company with managing all for you it
would make less because that's fast if
your hands on isn't it doesn't matter
move if you're I know a lot of people
making a thousand a month and probably
hands off yeah hundreds at hands off
yeah there you go
it depends on the areas depends on how
good the properties or some stuff so you
just go there start looking okay so you
want me to take the mick out you for
that
I don't care doesn't she like what does
it help you like like stop doing it like
Jen do as much anymore do tonight no
okay okay right okay okay okay okay
Danny morally in bold capital letters
it's like he's showing ours I mean did
what you show him for get some guests on
the podcast you wants us to get some
guests on the podcast have an
interesting interesting question I
always like us not getting guess cuz it
is the problem of guests right there's
two problems of guests our problem of
one yeah is if you get a boring guest
and here
which most people are you know let's
face it they're not going to be as fun
as ours it's not right they're either
they're either done what they're talking
about with it balling my guess on we see
we just don't we're talking about if
yeah if you get if you get a guest on
you've got a like work really hard to
keep right so I mean lets you got some
good guests in mind you bring someone
and the other thing is that's the main
thing that's the main reason they're
born and then the other thing is
difficult it with us it's because we're
like working there anyway it's so easy
just to film and it's weird absolutely
think about it like we want this to be
about us not about the guests no guys
this is about you but we're not having
guest value but mainly us so yeah so if
you want if you want guests come look at
four for Thursday all winners on a
Wednesday yeah
or perhaps start your own podcast but I
think they want I think the point is
they want to watch maybe May I'm gonna
have one a year let's do it look are a
yearly guest special I don't know but
then we're building up then then they're
like oh it's coming really good just get
the cleaner janitor maybe maybe what we
should do is we should occasionally swap
one of us out for a guest okay just for
a laugh yeah we don't like guests yeah
okay also I feel like it's like to
contact the pick out them where is him
up Lane to him you know it's fun I can
take it I can take it you take it like a
champ don't you take it like a champ
right okay so final question for today
before we get this wonderful episode
wrapped up I have got as this guy from a
guy called Alexander Cunningham do do me
man what an awesome surname clearly
you're from Scotland and clearly you're
a good guy obviously and so I've got one
for you guys there's only ever two
cooking them as I can think of one ones
not okay how where to go at transferring
a mortgage from my name to a limited
company in Scotland and is it possible
or if I wanted to buy a lot of this in
the future would I have to get my first
house under a limited company name
I personally buy
all companies in a limited company it
didn't make sense do that again just
count no again oh it's it's saying it
said or if I wanted to buy a lot of
properties in the future would I get my
first house under the limited company in
name I would buy all properties in a
limited company name properties okay
Alexander I cannot answer the first
question about transfer mortgage from my
name to a limited company in Scotland
because we do not know the law and we're
not here to advise about since it's
tough but I believe it's possible it's
possible I have spoke to a cash buyer is
possible but in many cases not worth it
not financially well yeah yeah and speak
to an accountant they'll give you the
better more sort of legal and
professional advice than us - we're not
gonna give you the professional advice
and we can just do it but it's not the
right advice is it so we'll just speak
to your accountant that says bass we're
going to give you speak to accountant
and one more property question from
Nathaniel Hannes what's involved in
managing a hit two more property
yourself before eventually outsourcing
it you can tip that because you've used
to run quick move imagine yourself okay
so first of all you've got to find the
tenants yeah
which involves doing viewings so you
stick it on someone like spare room and
trick the phone going and doing viewings
getting it filled once you've done that
you if you manically manage it yourself
you need to make sure you've got all the
relevant compliance because you're
basically letting agency it's all that
right to rent all all that jazz
basically because you want to take a
deposit all I always recommend taking
the deposit as well no some people don't
for HMOs but HMOs is the one place where
you really should because yeah because
you get people that can't afford to pay
and things like that basically it sounds
like an awful lot of Bali yeah you
traveling a lot to the properties doing
a lot of viewings that's all stuff and
then being available to answer the phone
I was just gonna say because I hate your
tenants tend to fall out with each other
and they tend to ring you Oh so-and-so
left the kitchen in a Mersenne do you
know so and so they didn't flush the
toilets
it literally is that is the source and
I'm not either [ __ ] cook have you got a
hand could you flush it well I could do
better
the point okay why don't you flush it
for now and then why don't you have an
adult conversation don't ring me I'm not
your mom and dad yeah
here's a little bit pathetic and he's
like my children
I must have met every time I've had any
dealings with my HMO tenants I'm like I
just want to punch them it's like you're
such a child they just grow them up yeah
there's Manoff we had other ones where
like there was no communal areas and
those were a lot easier I found okay you
guys have to spell it out to them so I
like the ones cuz I've had all right the
ones where they put numbers on the
numbers on the futon the cupboards yeah
it's like this is number one this is
number two because they moan about space
fridge Mase if you can make if you can
the problem is is when you when you've
not been doing that it's hard to
implement it because then they're like
oh you tripping like a child and it's
like yeah act like a child you yeah
basically but if you can make is easy
for them as possible to get along and
the rules have house rules first but
just make it as easy for them to get
along as possible it just makes it it
just makes it a little bit easier but
those houses I found work work better
larger bedrooms more space less communal
areas less chance for them to meet and
argue yes interact yeah yeah yeah I mean
sometimes I like it but Rommels I was
having a conversation with them one of
our Academy members and he's got hitch
and one Scunthorpe and you talk about
neighbor tenants not getting on together
we didn't get on that well that he took
a crowbar up and beat the [ __ ] out of
walks there's literally the landlord did
no no no the downstairs tenant cuz the
noise he was making upstairs it been
going on for months and he got he got
that and fury literally went upstairs to
a crowbar metal bar and he started
beating beat him up and him the guy had
blood all over his face blood all over
the guy's wall in fiction he laid into
him just because the guy they had an
ongoing disagreement for a long time and
it all transpired because he wouldn't
turn his music down or something and it
just they ended up having a right old
ruckus and the police got called the
room got sort of cordoned off and made
unavailable for like well crime scene
got on all sorts I've never had that
yeah that was a place to pray
but I have had a similar but not knowing
he was bad I have had the police call
because they've been threatening about
about Senate's threatened over tenants
yeah about that couple of times when you
think about it I mean if you live in art
like this except for a small hitch more
but just like one bathroom one show are
it's for people all trying to get to
work at the same time generally they've
all get up at the same time they're all
cooking want to cook at the same time
and this to get on if you've got like a
clash it's difficult that's why I would
always try and house the same sort of
hydrants professional it seems like a
laborious tenants like like imagine if
you lived in a charm or with like I
don't know yeah we'd get on fine yeah
initial if you got put in a tenant and
are in a job with them and if you got
put in a hitch em or with somebody late
for instance that sat every night down
the pub and was drinking every night you
you would clash because it's not it's
not your lifestyle and what will annoy
me noise sleep yeah I'm just
inconsiderate no bed noise in the day
whenever their the kitchen and stuff
like that I'd want my own bathroom for
sure I'm saying well yeah just make it
as easy as you can for them to it I just
can't I can't stand inconsiderate people
I just can't stand inconsiderate people
and I couldn't live in a hate you more
could you didn't hate you know like I
just described where you've got your own
kitchen out you've got your own bathroom
I'll see I could why not maybe very very
short term by settling often length time
I've had to from month or would but not
for any length your own kitchen your
bathroom I'll tell you why because
you're in the same house is because I
just have I'm quite in the same house
because you just you've got your own
room you know live in any way over than
your own yeah you've gone into the same
building and then you if it's a flat
isn't it you want you living the same
building as people yeah it depends how
segregated it is if it's got like new on
entrance and yeah if I'm if I'm sharing
any stock communally really know
because I just find I find a lot people
so inconsiderate and like yeah that
causes a clash because I'd and maybe
they think I mean I actually don't care
what you think but he doesn't care what
you think but he wants to have lots of
views about you know not opinions but
every certainly I couldn't live with any
of my HMO tenants
yeah that blame you know and on that
bombshell it's time to end guys so so
much tuning in we'll be back next week
at 7 o'clock to see you next Saturday do
not forget to subscribe to the channel
[Music]
[Applause]